Barb's in Montana I just went from
part-time to full-time at my job my
incomes almost doubled we only have
around $24,000 and a line of credit and
a leased car every question you get
usually revolves around someone having
multiples of our debt so the question is
is the advice for someone drowning in
debt the same as those who are just
waiting through it yes the advice is the
same all debt is standing between you
and becoming wealthy your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
when you give some of it or a bunch of
it to someone else you don't have it
anymore that's a mathematical fact when
you pay car payments on a stupid fleeced
car and you have a twenty four thousand
dollar line of credit buying crap you
couldn't afford and you pay payments on
that stuff you don't have the money
anymore if you had that money you could
have used it for investing and for
generosity and so yeah you get very very
intense the good news is is that you can
get out of debt quicker you didn't
mention your income in your email
request for an answer but you can get
out of that quicker probably because you
don't have the multiples of debt that a
lot of people do lady earlier this hour
- and $25,000 in debt you probably have
more like $50,000 in debt depending on
the price of this fleeced automobile but
the point is get rid of the debt because
without any payments what you have is
money and then that gives you options
now money is not the end of the world
but not having money sometimes is money
is what you feed your kids are with
money is what you pay the light bill
with and keep the heat and the cool on
money is what you keep a roof over your
family with my
is how you help other people generally
speaking it's hard to feed hungry kids
if you're poor and so this is that this
is what money's for it's just a tool
it's not got any existential there's no
existential Beauty to it
it's only for what it's good for it's a
tool it's like I have a car what's the
car for getting to work taking my family
on a vacation going to see grandma's
house this is what your cars for but
your car is not got you know it doesn't
change your life it's what the car does
that changes your life instead of
walking or riding an ox cart you have a
car that's all money is it's just a tool
so the point is yeah barb let's get rid
of the debt because then you have more
money and it's not again it's not a
spiritual problem to have more money
spiritual problems when you worship it
so get after it kiddo get your mess
cleaned up and listen you're in a real
dangerous position every question you
get usually revolves around someone
having multiples of debts so the
question is is the advice for someone
drowning in debt the same as it is for
those waiting out honey don't wait out
your language reveals that you are not
nearly concerned about this enough I
want you to get more angry about this
they're taking your money